welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar overcoming
challenges and you code cell culture
platform development presented by dr.
Waymon Lin principal scientists at Anne
bricks
my name is executors and I will be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by libraries
laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars now before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem
this presentation is educational invest
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Lin I will now
turn the presentation over to her
afternoon everyone first elected sankt
organizers for the invitation and
opportunities to share with you what I
have learned about you code technology
and the cell culture platform
development the topic of my presentation
today is overcoming the challenges in
you code cell culture platform
development today I will talk about what
is you codes technology and how we
overcome the challenges in you code cell
culture platform development I will also
provide a couple of case studies for
each category and then wrapped up with
some you code technology applications
and the pipeline
so what is the you code technology.you
stands for eukaryotic so you code is a
unique engineered eukaryotic cell
expression system here is a model of
original expression systems
you
not like a fact
prax we engineered our own Osaka no tRNA
and our s Pierce into the cell lines to
synthesize a protein consistent of non
natural amino acid at any site that can
be used in congregation without being
interfered by the other twenty amino
acids the non natural amino acid we're
using is called pas which is also called
the twenty-first amino acid you call the
technology as being implemented onto
multiple platforms to create larger and
more complex proteins where
site-specific and the homogeneous post
translational modification may be needed
for example the you code enabled ADC the
y-shaped atom is the antibody
the gray and the black items are the
linkers and the payload
the bright right size are the non-metro
eminence size
the you code technology empowered us to
be able to optimize the position of the
conjugation linker design and the
functional payload the key of the you
code technology is spy specific that
means you use a DC as an example to show
what advantages of having site-specific
conjugation over the conventional
conjugation
the conventional conjugation
technologies lead to it organism
mixtures which presents the challenges
in optimizing the biological physical
and the pharmaceutical properties of a
disease the therapeutic windows or index
for many ABC's that are currently in
preclinical or clinical development
remains very narrow site-specific
conjugate ADCs have eliminated enter
Jinna t and thus demonstrated better CMC
properties such as generating
homogeneous ADCs with fuel conjugated
drugs providing a more stable linkers in
vivo over this and lead to wider
therapeutic index
you
thing is too good to be true right
here comes the challenges when
generating the production cell line from
the platform cell line the non natural
amino acid which is the PAF is needed to
generate a site-specific protein without
PF cells can only produce truncated
proteins in the present of PF those can
produce full-length proteins but
depression rate is only about 10 to 30
percent it means how to improve
productivity is going to be challenging
down the road in process development
you
are the step-by-step approaches from
expression system and asset development
to clone selection and then process
development
these are also the foundation of the you
code cell culture platform dog culture
process development starts with downline
generation and the selection followed by
median and the process development and
optimization in small skill systems
including 96 well-placed sheikha flags
and the bench skill directors or high
throughput screening purpose once
conditions are defined the process is
often transferred to a task queue to
test the scalability and the produce
materials for preclinical tox studies
and then large scale manufacturing for
production of a clinical material and
the cGMP regulations
once the development of commercial cell
culture process is completed at lab and
the pass queues their commercialization
process begins with process
prioritization you up tech transfer and
validation of the manufacturing process
as cell culture technologies maturing
the biopharmaceutical industry has
applied platform process to satisfy
median mind and the quality requirement
within a short period of time
the first step is to develop a
expression system of course you need to
identify target and isolate gene before
develop expression systems therapeutic
anybody's are mainly produced in Lebanon
hosts beltline the selection of the
expression system is determined by its
ability to deliver high productivity
with acceptable product quality
attributes and the preference of
individual companies
you
protocol needs to be set up to screen
and the select highest producing and the
most stable call
and this stage the key is knowing Jing
for the protein you want what cell line
to use and what cone forms that cell
line is the best
so life there's a perhaps no other
factor like a culture medium that can
more greatly influence process
performance once a successful growth and
the production median for each salon has
been developed the culture medium
familiar and the details of how it was
developed are often two of the most
closely guarded secrets of the
manufacturer a indicates how important
median development is to overall process
development
so many commercial medians are ready to
use hydrolysis is so powerful we still
want to develop chemical define medians
how can we identify the components in
Culture Media Oh many combinations when
to see them how about inducers or
promoters these are the questions we
need to answer one by one
nowadays using chemically defined
medians have become the standard in the
biotech industry here are some of the
motivations of why we need to divide 10
codify millions these motivations are
pretty much well known now so I will
read through all of this but next I
would like to share some experimental
geology
approaches can be used systematically
such as single components titrations and
medians analysis and the medium blending
downline is very sensitive for the
median change so normally you should
start with own needed nutrients using
published formulation
you can prove all nutrients based on the
solubility or the nutrient category and
then twice dosing response situations
and yogi studies
here is the perfora de workflow
we're bottles you start with the single
component screening then go up to the
screening model then you adjust your
formulations and then testing and
measuring you know your uptake rate and
the performance
after several runs eventually you will
success
you
those that those the response hydration
studies are very time and labor
consuming so you can modify your shake
fax screening protocol instead of it
taking 14 days of a full production time
you can initiate the production stage in
a larger vessel for six or seven days
and then split into shaker flags with
different conditions or factors
after 24 to 72 hours measure BC and
pattern if there's a no possible
response do nothing if there's a showing
positive response moving forward to do
is starting
you
if you
mber 15 buy it and are you're going to
love it
in this study we try to replace a
hydrolysate containing commercial media
with the in-house developed chemical
defined media initial phase on medians
derived from a MDM with enrichment in
amino acids and the trees elements
you
initial feed media was partially
concentrated from based on media with
the removal of excess in organic
inorganic assault
the amino acid concentration was it
harmed by calculation of uptake rate
titration of a trace element and the
supplementation of ratings in both basal
median and the C median you can see the
graph the commercial PDMS is in stark
blue and the chemical if a media is in
light blue comparing the growth profile
BCD is much higher in commercial media
viability is about the same it is
interesting to see that even
VCT in chemical defy median is lower
than in commercial media the harvest
titers are very similar it means that QP
in chemical 85 media is much higher in
compared to in a commercial media
so the enhancement of a specific
productivity per cell is achieved by
combining both optimization of immediate
compensation and the director operation
conditions
people here on the right is show very
comparable now those are the result tell
us now that unusual to see in this kind
of approvement
things you are only one no your cell
line the most not a vendor if it's
possible you should have developed your
own media of course chemical defiant
media is performed
process development is often divided
into early and the late stage with each
having different goals
the goal of early-stage development is
to rapidly develop by process to produce
materials for phase 1 and the phase 2
clinical trials and the tox studies
standardized process conditions and the
procedures are essential
the process may not be fully optimized
for every molecule as the product moves
into late stage development process can
be further optimized
to optimize the conditions for bio
manufacturing process normally is in a
student version like a bench skill but
some companies even use ember 15 for
process development or early stage then
directly queue up to 2,000 liters
when you optimize the process you need
to consider what temperature any shift
what oxygen level you to pH and it
shipped when to harvest
you
we were working on the process
optimization we all need to remember
that most important thing is to deliver
meaningful scalable data
culture operating parameters include
physical chemical and biological
parameters physical parameters included
temperature gas flow and agitation speed
well the chemical parameters include a
deal
po2 pH osmolarity and metabolite levels
including substrate United State and the
waste byproducts
biological parameters are usually used
for determining the physiological state
of the culture and including VCD
durability and more the others
variations in the macro-environment
parameters from optimal levels and have
a dramatic impact on the culture
performance productivity and the product
ecology appropriate online and offline
sensors can provide a lot of information
that can enhance the process control
you
um I was supposed to share temperature
share of the modeling pace today but
rejected by the legal so I will share a
feeding strategy optimization case study
after platform process established
optimizing of feeding strategy is super
critical to achieve a culture that both
grows and produce the protein
effectively in this case study we based
the process of ization of feeding
strategy of nutrients inducer and the
growth factors work done simplify the
feeding strategy was implemented during
the complexion in the titer was
increased twofold
more complex the feeding strategy was
implemented during the process
development and the titer was increased
five to six volts
so downline medians and the feeding
strategy a 3t for this cell culture
platform development
you
the ultimate goal of all the work we
have done so far is for us to be able to
skill up the process in large skill by
writer or production of therapeutics
you
director operating conditions Europe
agitation and eration are two important
conditions to be skilled up properly to
achieve comparable process performance
across different skills agitation is
suggest that you provide a sufficient
mixing and oxygen mass transport and
it's generally skilled using eco
specific energy imputation rate when
aspiration ISM modulated for a profit
supply of oxygen and the removal of
excess co2
in small skill directors the operating
parameters are typically wider because
mixing is generally not a problem even
at relatively low agitation speed and
the co2 removal is efficient due to
large surface to volume ratio in large
skill by writers these parameters need
to be selected carefully as agitation
related shear force for example impeller
tip speed and aeration related co2
accumulation may increase with skill
codified a cell culture skilled our
model is very crucial it can provide the
necessary information to assess and
resolve any unexpected performance
problem of the large skill system
young manufacturing support the school
model can also be used for process
characterization and the validation
experiment to study
accessable ranges of process operating
parameters and the determining the
critical operating parameters
you
her two is our fourth the clinical
program
in this case today
we successful skew up from five liter to
500 liter and then 2000 liter we build
up the student model and the later we
implement untie her to steal the Moto to
develop an type a PS main program
therefore later of course when we skew
up and type es many programs there was
no issues
well five liter to GMP 500 liters
so this is indicate skilled on model is
super useful where you doing the skill
up for any process
we have developed you code the cell
culture platform the system can rapidly
provide the amount of material needed at
all stage of study for anybody molecule
selection range the from milligrams of
screening needs in two weeks 200 grams
of the tox run in eight weeks once these
molecule is selected table cell line can
be generated in six months with titer
about one to two grams per liter to
support clinical trials and the
potential commercialization
you
in summary you code the cell culture
platform has been developed and
validated by multiple programs the
productivity of a platform cell line was
improved by five to fold to about the
five to six votes
you
production cell line generation process
was shortened to six months by using
platform cell line engineering and the
process of them ization
you
and the multi programs have been
demonstrated tighter of one to two gram
per liter of manufacturing ability and
up to 2,000 liter of a scalability
you
establish the you code cell culture
platforms can generate site-specific and
homogeneous biomolecules it empowers you
code technology to many applications
besides ADC we also have have life
extension by specific party vaccines and
more in flux development
you
you code technology is the best in class
non-natural amino acid technology there
are many pipelines currently in clinical
research if you are interested in your
code technology or you code the cell
culture platform is contact us
definitely a team effort between the
cell line development group and the cell
culture development group
thank you so much for your attention
Thank You dr. Lin for that informative
presentation I would also like to thank
laberd's for making today's educational
webcast possible and before we go and
want to let everyone know that this
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through April of 2019
as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you next time goodbye